my name is jen lewin and i'm an
interactive
light artist i create interactive sound
and led art
that can be the scale of a landscape
humans across the planet love light and
we immediately get
interacting with light and so i can
create a light interaction
piece and everyone participates and
plays with it and understands it
my largest piece is called cosmos it's
over 15 000
square feet and had 240 000 leds my work
has been shown in over 18 countries
i think the pool has been to over 15
countries and hundreds of exhibitions
the very first pool was actually an
honorarium grant from burning man in
2008.
i built it i had to bring it back and
rebuild it and in fact i think the
pool's been fully re-engineered and
rebuilt probably over
10 times at this point there was a lot
of learning in creating a work like that
and as
i got better at building the work and
better at implementing my vision then
the work became more mobile and was able
to travel around the world
[Music]
there's been something really magical
about being on the team moving the pool
around and seeing how
in all of these really different places
everyone jumps in and plays
and when you kind of get down to the
core behavior of humans and play
everyone plays the same way
kids immediately get it adults you know
hesitate a little bit more everyone
takes photos
but in the end you sort of see this
really amazing connectiveness
between all of us which is what the
sculpture's about too so to have the
sculpture be about that and then to have
it move around the world and to really
see that
has been special the beginning phase of
any project there's a long period of
time where i just let ideas percolate
so i'll spend a lot of time actually
flying through the site
and analyzing the site in 3d kind of
step one is being able to understand the
space
at that point then i come up with an
idea and then i i don't actually sketch
it on paper i render it in 3d
once we have a three-dimensional model i
sit down with my team and we start to
figure out how to build it
it could be up to year to year inventive
process of figuring it out
because it's almost never
straightforward how are we going to make
it what can we do and so there's this
amazing process of iteration and
invention
we're building new circuit boards we're
trying to figure out what the software
will be we're writing software we're
testing things
so there's just constant experimentation
finally we come up with a prototype
we all approve of the prototype and then
we go into fabrication and in most of my
works that means you take the prototype
and you make a thousand of them so
there's a lot of verification there's a
lot of repetition we assemble everything
here
in the studio and then there's a testing
phase where you have to test everything
methodical testing of every component
testing all the leds you have final
assembly and then eventually you go to
the site and you bring it all together
i think that's the interesting thing
about my process it's really looking at
all of the pieces and then figuring out
how you can bring them all together
it's not just one or the other so it's
both the material how the material is
going to work with the circuit board
and then how the lighting is going to
work within that i love it i think my
favorite days are actually my software
days where i get to sit and
write code all day i loved computers and
programming from a very early age i was
part of an experimental
program a really awesome experimental
program called logo
where i learned to program in third
grade but i was from
a little bit of an earlier generation
where you were supposed to pick
it was left brain or right brain so you
were supposed to be an artist or you
were supposed to be an engineer
and i rather stubbornly refused to do
that and just decided i was going to do
both
this is actually all of the custom
software that's running the aurora
sculpture in minneapolis
and i'm looking at video that i've
created and composed
and it's actually being mapped to an led
array that then is physically in the
space
this is interesting software because
it's also pulling in weather data it's
looking at
live live weather and based on whether
it's like creating all these different
playlists so if there's a weather
condition of rain it will actually play
a rain video what you're looking at here
on this screen is actually another piece
of software that we built internally
that allows us to communicate with any
of our
projects and i'm actually communicating
with an xp radio that's an xp radio
and i can for example set all sorts of
parameters so i have this
curtain downstairs and if i wanted to i
can actually
trigger a stored palette
i'm looking at a blue palette here but i
could actually compose
a new palette right now that would then
get stored onto the work permanently so
if i left then the work would actually
display that
and use that as sort of a future color
so i'm really creating like a
skeleton structure for all of these
different kinds of lighting conditions
and then i'm creating an interactive
seed and then i'm allowing people to
play within those conditions
[Music]
ground-based pieces are really unusual
and different compared to most
pieces like this there's no single
master computer in the pool
or aqueous or cosmos or any of my
ground-based pieces many years ago i
made a decision to
build these pieces as mesh networks and
that was actually an unusual decision at
the time now it's much more common
because we have all these smart devices
in our home
early 2000s that was not common each
platform is smart
it has all of this intelligence it knows
you're standing on
it it can animate and then all of the
platforms communicate with each other
from a code perspective
it can be really interesting because you
actually are very constrained in what
you can do
but you have to build this sort of very
organic
system that is meshable that allows for
this dynamic mesh network to be created
[Music]
so these are some of the components that
were used in the aurora which is
a recent sculpture we installed in
minneapolis you're just looking at some
of the prototyping we had to prototype
an
aluminum ring form so you can see one
here that i've actually
glued together to prototype the final
aurora is built out of
a welded aluminum form and this is just
a model of one hanging up here
but in the aurora are thousands of glass
bulbs
so it's actually what looks like a
traditional glass bulb it's just not
wired so it doesn't have any kind of
incandescent
wiring in it and then we had this piece
made this is a custom acrylic piece
that actually was injection molded and
then we built and designed these really
cool
led rings and they have a custom
injection molded piece on it and three
leds
the system is really interesting because
basically you can attach a glass bulb
and then you can screw on the led on the
back and then all of these leds can
chain together
creating thousands of them but still
creating this sort of transparent
twinkle if you look at it you can sort
of see through it
and clearly this is just a prototype so
the difference with this prototype is
our boards in the back are actually
black
and i didn't want that opacity i wanted
them to be semi-transparent so if you
look at the
ones that we actually made they have
this really beautiful more
semi-transparent
glow to them so just examples of a large
art piece that requires
many many different components
to me there's something so intrinsically
interesting
about this element of participation
bringing people into the work and
allowing them to create this
relationship
with the work where it's the work and
them all of the work has that piece of
it at his heart that idea of being part
of something and
being able to create that connection
within public art
there really aren't that many moments
where we get to play music together
collaboratively the harps are really
designed with sounds that allow you to
run around
play and actually have this music
experience without necessarily knowing
how to play music
so it really becomes a participatory
experience in light and see this really
beautiful
light effect on their hands
[Music]
this is um the guts of one of my newer
laser harps we have it out here we're
prototyping it
this harp is using a custom sensor what
this is doing is actually sending out an
infrared beam and it's triangulating
that beam off of my hand and
sending back both distance information
as well as sort of the
speed of change so all of that
information is being sent i'm actually
triggering it right now it's being sent
back to a custom controller that's a
little bit away from us
it's not as simple as just a single note
and you'll hear on several of the notes
that the notes change over time
and that there's like a grace and a
breathiness to the notes
so that you're not just triggering a
single note you feel like you want to
move through the notes and play them
all of my work has an easter egg in it
which means there's some sort of
component
that if you trigger and find will affect
other components
in the case of my laser harps there is a
laser which we call the magic laser
and if you trigger that laser you'll
change the sound so right now you can
hear these kind of smooth and ethereal
sounds but if i hold this
particular laser i know which one it is
i've changed the sounds
so by holding it for that extended
period of time the sounds have changed
in my ground-based pieces there's
usually a magical platform that when you
stand
on will change the entire color palette
for the rest of the sculpture
this is going actually to a playground i
build what are called magical harps for
the magical bridge foundation which
creates accessible playgrounds
so it goes into a playground that's
really meant to inspire kids
of all ability to be able to play and
create music the hardest aspect to learn
of all of my work has been the hardware
there's so much of building hardware
that just comes from a lifetime of
building hardware and i'm going to be
learning
forever over time the tools have become
so much more sophisticated so our
circuit boards have strength in size
[Music]
almost everyone who starts building
hardware starts on breadboards this is a
breadboard example of
the second laser harp i ever made and
it's programmed with a pic
microcontroller
looks like the microcontroller actually
popped out in the end it only took me a
few days to assemble
it took me months to figure out and
learn how to make i was just learning
electronics and so i actually had to
really figure out how everything was
going to work i had to do all the math
and computation
to understand how the circuit was
actually going to function things change
this is one of the og
prototypes for one of the first pool
sculptures i like to keep it around very
scary looking for me
but this is one of the internal pieces
all of this was hand built
hundreds and hundreds of hours of
actually soldering because we made
hundreds of these
all handmade and then of course
something like this has become much more
elegant i don't have components on this
but much
smaller more elegant boards and actually
everything you see here
plus probably 10 times as much as done
now on this board which
looks much cleaner
[Music]
so this is indicative of either my
temporary or permanent work we have a
custom
circuit board that's a wireless
networkable component
there's obviously a power supply right
now we're testing everything
and making sure that it's ready we're
burning in our leds and keeping them
running for several weeks
once we know that this is a go we'll
then go through the process of
waterproofing it
we experimented a lot with coatings and
we've used a lot of different kinds of
coatings
now we actually pot all of our
electronics which essentially means we
fully encase them
in a particular type of type of resin so
they're bricked per se in resin
and then we test them by actually
sitting them in water or soaking them in
water for days we've actually had tests
where we've had pieces submerged for
a week then heating up the water and
cooling the water and dealing with
temperature changes that might also
affect something that's wet it's no
small feat to make a sculpture with
hundreds of electronics that you jump on
and a sculpture that can be rained on
and snowed on
and deal with really you know very
interactive behavior
the first time i saw people interact
with my work i had this sort of
surprised moment because up to that
point i'd been so
caught up and so focused on the
technology and making the technology
work
that i really hadn't stepped back to
sort of see how joyful the piece could
be
i wanted something integrated i wanted
something
kids liked and grandparents liked and
different cultures liked i
feel inclined to want that and desire
that
and i want to see pieces in community
that truly engage with community
and community is diverse to create
public art
to create these places and to affect
space requires
or i think it requires having the desire
to bring everyone together
to me public art at its best can really
create a sense of place
and a sense of place is really important
it's how a community aligns with where
they live
it brings in other people and it really
connects
[Music]
you know those living in a place with
where they are i hope that young people
play with technology more and i want to
see more artists working within this
medium
artist making dynamic connected
high-tech beautiful artwork
you